what do you see for the midterms and
what do you advise candidates Now Kevin
McCarthy it's first time in 28 years
that Republicans are doing something
similar to the contract with America
he's calling it commitment to America uh
he will he will release that publicly on
Friday
um I think many Senate candidates will
also sign on to it it's your agenda it's
the Maga agenda it is the America First
agenda which by the way Joe Biden gave
an entire speech on did you see I know
you saw the speech because you mentioned
it in your way you talked about Maga
it's make America great again you know
how do you attack make America great
again it's under attack I Define my
political philosophy
um very simply I'm a conservative I'm a
registered conservative because I'm in
New York okay I believe in Liberty
freedom capitalism our constitution Law
and Order Safety and Security or else
you can't pursue happiness right right
okay I want choice in school we spend
more per capita per education with the
worst results you talk about it often I
believe in Secure borders legal
immigration uh I believe in energy
Independence I'd like to see that next
step like you talk about for energy
dominance okay I want NATO to pay its
fair share free and fair trade which you
talked a lot about peace through
strength you got to have the best
military on the face of the Earth we
have a lot of Bad actors
and I believe that the Supreme Court
should interpret the Constitution and
not write legislation now and we believe
in the first and second amendment that's
pretty much sums up who I've been on air
now 36 years I've been on radio and 27
at Fox whatever it's 26. and that's not
conservative you know what that is
common sense I agree okay I often say
are you a conservative I'm a person with
common sense strong borders energy
Independence great education strong
military strong military all of these
things low taxes they're going to double
triple your taxes it's crazy you know
even from a political standpoint how
crazy is it my whole life the man who
was going to lower taxes always had or
woman always had the advantage right in
an election today they're talking about
openly we're going to raise how about
you're talking about nuclear weapons
which is the biggest threat in the world
today by far and we have a president at
the United Nations today that goes on
and talks about global warming and
climate change you know it used to be
called global warming but that was a
working tool so now they called before
that it was global cooling the next ice
age is coming years ago was they thought
it was a global cooling but
I mean we have such problems in this
country and if you look at the green New
Deal the trillions and trillions of
dollars we're spending on this it's like
throwing it out the window a big Reason
by the way for this inflation the other
big reason is what they allowed to
happen to energy energy has gone so high
so fast it was devastating it lifted
everything else now everything else is
caught up it's not merely energy let me
ask you if you were to run again and win
if you were to win and became president
you know we would only be able to serve
one term
how long do you believe you could get
things back to where you had it when you
left very quickly except for one thing
millions of people are in our country
now that shouldn't be here many of them
are prisoners would you Deport them
criminals the bad ones I would Deport
yeah the bad ones I would Deport
millions and millions of people
have
they're poisoning our country they're
poisoning I'd like to be nice about it
yesterday I heard that Venezuela is
emptying their prisons out into the
United States now I was in that check
because other countries have been doing
it and I've been hearing about it and
reading about it and seeing it so I'm
almost surprised it took them so long
but Venezuela is emptying their prison
population into the United States going
right through the Border like nothing
we're poisoning our country and it's
very hard to come back from that we can
come back I will get the oil we'll get
the price down you know if we got the
price of oil down we would stop I
wouldn't even have to talk to them Putin
would stop because he wouldn't be able
to afford it he wouldn't be able to go
forward but he's making so much money
even above and beyond the cost of war
and he's selling it to China and he's
selling it to other places
and Europe is going to dump us you watch
because they're not going to allow their
people to freeze so they're going to
dump us we're out there fighting we're
spending many times more money than them
and they get they will be dumping us you
know we did one thing very bad we
allowed Russia and China to unify that's
a very bad thing hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else